the outer you technician a Greg at 11
Kombat pack official Terminator t800 do
you talk through gameplay trailer dude
it's not Van Damme let's do this
nice here we go that's off subject
cyborg it's good enough for me
that's that's your bad oh dude great to
play as Oh
I hope you get time travel ah defeat
your opponent his baby that's so cool
over there
[Music]
that's our sir
oh nice oh yes he's doing it yeah so
poor jack
not you to prevent to send you me to
finish you the future Cassie Quinn huh
look out now awesome hmm those early
access I love it I really love it like a
lot of times when they do these DLC
characters especially off of iconic
characters that are like oh I really
hope it's great to play as them I
usually find that it's cool to pick them
and then when I play as them I'm not as
entertained as I was hoping I would be I
have a high standard apparently and when
it comes to my mortal combat gaming
experience first off he's doing some
iconic moves that I love terminator
being one of my all-time favorite films
from rare to specifically but he does
the shotgun twirl or chance reload
badass I didn't notice how it's similar
to some other Mortal Kombat characters
you can teleport he uses that over that
time travel mechanism missed a teleport
then of course you got the finishing
combo and I was just joking but humor
time he travels the beginning of the
finisher is a time-travel move or he's
send them into the world the judgement
day which i think is great yeah I mean
just the way he moves in like punches
and does some some type of like WWE kind
of moves yeah yeah I think is
appropriate for him and also you know
some of the lines here I think are great
yeah our old voice probably could have
gotten up John Bailey where you at man
you will be terminated in it you are
terminated it gets the job done you got
the lines you got the look he gives a
thumbs up it would mum or shoot it like
yeah I mean this hasn't the only thing
is you should be naked every time he
teleports man I think that's a really
big plot hole in the game I feel like he
should wake off his clothes he should do
deal as opponent that should be the
finishing move is you take your
opponent's clothes and then send them
back yeah your clothes I need your
clothes
and you motorcycle you should roll it on
a motorcycle too and shoot people that
would be really cool let's just get
every element of the movie in here and
then let's get the t1000 more DLC half
the Gabriel lunar Terminator is good we
could get him in there yeah this really
was great yeah Plus that finishing move
like besides the Future stuff is just
gnarly well I love the addition to how
when his skin melts off he's still not
done because he's an X the endoskeleton
I forget the exact terminology when he
tells John Connor sure yeah throw that
clip you're like a mission underneath
right let's order it alive that side I'm
a cybernetic organism living tissue over
metal endoskeleton yeah how he could
still move referencing Terminator 1 oh
so clever that's like a clever way to
infuse that I think yeah they don't see
it coming you're like oh cool he's
melted oh whatever it's Corbin Eva tries
to grab him but can't oh that's clever
that's really clever
yeah I didn't recognize those purple
like energy blast bomb thingies from the
movies maybe my recollection one of the
Infinity stones
oh is that he's got the Power Stone good
those look neat but those were the only
aesthetic thing where I was going what
wood is that you know that kind of I
guess you've distracted me but you know
can't play this game now ah it's not up
to my impossibly high standards that I
goddamn usually if I'd say that you keep
going not today not today hello there I
mean we're ending all right guys you
excited with this t800 footage this was
great you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
I'd like to give a patient the day shot
so a man named Luke Anderson Oh Luke I
don't know where you've been the past
year but you have stayed pledged this
entire time so much so that we are
shooting this on October 1st you see on
patreon day one when
process of people who are pledged many
cards are declined a lot of people need
to update their payments a good
percentage actually especially with
those are the shoutouts here a lot of
times their pledges come through late
every month including today hey you've
been gone absent and your pledge still
went through day one of month thanks man
clearly you have forgotten about this
Auto payment you have on file and that's
okay with me so thank you for being you
buddy
I hope work is going great I hope
prayers to God are serving you at the
highest of all my tea I love you bud
let's hope this consistency continues
till January 2020
or until your card is canceled and you
get a new one